[Musique]
mi-octobre dans lanaudière
les récoltes ont déjà eu lieu le temps
est venu de nettoyer et préparer les
courges pour la vente
[Musique]
ça a été une bonne année pour la ferme
familiale de lanoraie qui compte
maintenant sur un nouveau partenaire
pierre-luc hervieux 28 ans appartient à
la relève agricole ans qu'on produit
principalement de la course vers puis du
maïs sucré on a des marins aspergeraie
en régie biologique cette année puis un
petit peu de courge souris biologique
aussi depuis deux ans pierre-luc reprend
une ferme au sol sablonneux qui ont été
généreux pour la culture du tabac
jusqu'en 2003
car pierre luc est fils et petit fils de
producteur de tabac
[Musique]
il fait partie de ces jeunes déterminés
à mettre en valeur la terre qu'ils
reçoivent faut préserver qu'est ce qu'on
a pu en prendre soin puis ça m'est venu
de mon grand père de mon père aussi
compter le vent puis on fait attention
aussi à la terre qu'on au kiosque ulti
présentement il garde le 4 mai va plus
loin en pratiquant ce qu'on appelle
l'agriculture raisonnée c'est à dire
qu'il réduit au minimum les pesticides
chimiques
par exemple dans le maïs sucré au lieu
de l'insecticide qui élimine la pyrale
seul insecte trichogrammes qu'il utilise
pour diminuer les herbicides les semis
de courges sont faits sur payet de
seigle et ce champ de poids et d'avoine
est une culture de couverture qui
devient de l'engrais vert une fois
faucher est enfoui dans le sol en
gardant le sol couverts l'on empêche
l'érosion éolienne puis en même temps on
a un faible taux matières organiques pas
qu'on préserve le plus de matière
organique mon nom en ayant toutes bonnes
plantes d'horreur qui est sur le sol
et voici sa toute nouvelle plantation
des asperges biologiques tels que
pratiqués en france réalisé en double
donc on a deux rats côte à côte sur la
butte
donc au lieu d'avoir un rang saint pour
cinq pions dans le radeau body pied puis
on sert du sol qui est entre les deux
rangs avec une machine pour pouvoir
lutter mécaniquement contre la mauvaise
herbe en trois ans car combattants
récolte grands graveurs vont être plus
autre que l'aspergent donc vous protéger
contre le vin contre le sable qui
pourraient aller se loger dans les
tailles des asperges l'agriculture
raisonnée c'est aussi une bonne gestion
de l'eau potable est justement sur la
rivière saint-jean qui traversent leurs
terres il y à un barrage
un héritage du temps de la culture du
tabac la mrc gère les niveaux de l'eau
et permet l'irrigation des terres de
tous les agriculteurs riverains
s'ils avaient pas savoir âge l'ont pas
signé non terre de sa robe bleue dans la
région en fait je pense que l'eau ça va
être un enjeu très important dans les
prochaines années
puis c'est de l'utiliser
consciencieusement le dernier dans les
bonnes périodes
pire le pousse plus loin son souci de
conserver l'eau potable avec ce bio
filtre
c'est un système qui récupère et
filtrent les zones de pulvérisation
[Musique]
options d'achat entre avec beaucoup de
matière active beaucoup de rinçage donc
ça permet d'éviter d'aller toujours
reims et au chant puis au lieu de
vidanger dans un endroit pour trait aux
normes
donc on installe un système de
filtration des rouges aux études au
cégep de joliette lors d'un stage en
europe
il avait vu une installation pareil il a
reçu les subventions du programme
primevères du mapaq et l'appui du
carrefour industriel et expérimentale de
lanaudière
mais il a dû remettre de l'argent c'est
quelque chose qu'ils ont eu à débourser
pour ravoir qui nous rapporte rien au
niveau monétaire au niveau des revenus
de l'entreprise mais qui fait un groupe
le saut au niveau de l'environnement
si la ferme et médaillés du concours de
l'ordre national du mérite agricole
c'est sans doute en partie grâce à ce
bio filtre cesser votre initiative et
c'est à la ferme
oui exactement c'est mon petit bébé ou à
mon projet dans le passé la famille
revient à planter des haies brise-vent
protéger la bande riveraine a mené la
rotation des cultures avec la production
de légumes la poursuite de la culture
maraîchère à la manière de pierre luc
plaît bien au grand père ferdinand
vanbelle relief et pour lui que son père
encore copropriétaire de la ferme
les projets de son fils ne cesse de
l'étonner en approchant soit de quoi
attendre de nos défis c'est ce que l'on
vieillit jeu des fois je faisais misère
avec les nouveaux défis mais toutes les
courges vont aux friteries et grande
épicerie au québec et en ontario
quand le marché pour à l'absorber
pire le projette d'augmenter encore la
production de courge biologique
voilà tout est prêt pour un autre voyage
le dernier ce soir les deux univers on
peut profiter un peu plus puis vive la
vie
pierre-luc fait jusqu'à trois
allers-retours par jour ces temps-ci
destination montréal centre-ville pour
la livraison des courges de la relève
c'est plus beau métier du mans mais
faut que ça soit plus qu'un métier ce
soit de patience non on ne peut pas
passer à travers
e